so here's three of only three of the
Platonic solids the things you can make
out of equilateral triangles so here
I've got tetrahedron for triangles
octahedron eight triangles in the
icosahedron 20 triangles what's changing
as you go from here to here to here is
how many triangles there are around each
corner on each vertex so the tetrahedron
rate has three triangles around a corner
and the octahedron has four and the
icosahedron has five what comes next
well six triangles around a vertex do
you get a platonic solid that has six
triangles on a vertex no no no what do
you get so all right so here's six so
here's you know there's one triangle two
two three four five six so six triangles
around a vertex that tiles the plane
right it goes on forever yes so it
doesn't have any curve to it so here's a
way to think about it so your triangle
has 60 degrees at this corner and so
like 60 plus 60 plus 60 those are the
three around here that adds up to 180
which is well less than 360 so it sort
of curves it makes a cone shape if you
do this with the octahedron you get 60
60 60 60 which is what 240 still less
than 360 with five of them you've got
300 when you get to six it has of the
360 right there's no there's no lack of
space there's no there's nothing missing
so it doesn't make a cone it just makes
it flat three four five six what happens
if you put even if you try and put seven
triangles on each vertex actually you
know what would be good to try drawing
it I'm not going to be able to make them
all equilateral but let's see how far we
can get so I got to fit seven so there's
going to be one here and then I got
fitted fit three in here so I got to do
this and all right so I fit seven around
a vertex so let's keep going so I got
two here already so maybe I'll do that
that's 5 6 7 2 2 2 2 2 3 I got to fit
four in here you can go for quite a
while actually before you start running
into trouble
1 2 3 4 you can speed this up right ok 1
2 3 4 I got to fit 3 in here you see it
starts getting difficult there's too
many of them they
don't really fit very nicely and you
start oh now I'm in real trouble look at
this one two three four I got to fit
three in here one two three four in here
so Wow I mean you can sort of see that
like this iswell try it at home right
how far can you get drawing triangles
seven triangles on each vertex what if I
don't do it on paper what if I do with
3d printed stuff then you get this thing
so right well you can see there one two
three four or five six seven triangles
around each vertex you know the first
thing you try and do is you try and lay
it flat and it doesn't work like you can
make bits of it be kind of flat and
there's some given the hinges which sort
of helps out but then it bunches up
somewhere else like there's just no way
to make it flat everywhere it doesn't
work right what is going on right these
are sort of like they're closed around
this or like spheres right three four
and five six is like the flat plane
sphere plane what is this thing trying
to be it doesn't look like it's some
nice surface is just some horrible thing
we don't know what seven is maybe eight
will be better
no no eight is not better right so this
is eight equilateral triangles around
each vertex like I mean you can count
them but like it's this horribly crinkly
it's sort of like it's like coral or
it's like lettuce so these are
positively curved things which like a
hill or a bowl sort of curves towards
you in all directions whereas like
something that's flat it's not it's not
curving at all or like like it can curve
in one direction but then the other
direction is is flat right as I map does
that make sense like it's curved this
way but it has to be flat this where you
can't curve it in both directions so one
of the directions is flat was really
just flat and these are like so it wants
to be like a saddle so you imagine my
hand is a horse right and like the hand
is like awesome like your legs go either
side of here so so right so what does
that mean like sometimes it's curving
towards you and sometimes it's curving
away from you so when you've got both of
those that's negative coach or negative
Gaussian curvature so what are these
things these are sort of like so these
are models of hyperbolic space in a way
there's sort of too much of it it
doesn't want to fit in or
Euclidean space it kind of wrinkles up
and gets out of control so these these
ones here right you you run out of
triangles right once you're done with
your twenty triangles on the I cost
evening you're done this one I could
have kept going forever right is it's
like I could just keep tying this
outwards and it was just you know fall
off the table and go off around the
world this one well so again I've only
done like a little bit of it it's it
seems clear that I could keep going I
mean I tried doing it over here with the
the pen but it was sort of you know it's
difficult but it seems like you know if
you're allowed to sort of wrinkle them
up out of the plane and like make this
sort of wrinkly thing then I could just
keep going well you kind of might run
into trouble so there's actually an open
question nobody knows the answer if you
keep adding these things how far can you
go out into space without it crashing
into itself I mean for this physical
thing there's a definite limit and and
here's here's the argument right so as
you sort of go out from like the sensual
ring to the next ring to the next ring
like the amount of space you've got to
play with is only going up like the the
cube of that distance because you're
making a sphere of possible places you
could put triangles but the number of
triangles that you need actually goes up
exponentially so exponential versus cube
you lose right you if you go like a few
layers out you'll just get incredible
numbers of triangles in a solid ball
because these are made of plastic that
has thickness like each one then the
house volume and I you just run out but
if you problem that's open is like
suppose they're two dimensional
triangles I connected at the hinges like
perfectly can you how far can you go is
there actually a limit because like two
dimensional triangles you could stack
like tons them next to each other and
maybe you'd somehow be able to fit them
in without crashing into each other we
don't think so
but there's no proof like nobody knows
what's the what's the the farthest now
you can go I mean it's sort of like
really crinkly and nasty and not really
smooth and in the same in same sort of
way like the icosahedron is not that
smooth it's got these sort of corners so
what you can do to an icosahedron to
make it smoother is like make a geodesic
dome so here's one way to do it right
you take each triangle and you subdivide
it into four you know like a Triforce
cut it into four and then you've got
these extra vertices on in the middle of
the edges and you push them out to the
fear and that makes a smoother
polyhedron it's no longer regular but
you know it's a smoother thing that's
more like a sphere so I was like all
right let's do that with this it's got
this crinkly thing that's too like here
that like that the angles that up to
what 360 plus 60 is 420 it's too many
there's like a lot of angle at each
vertex so if you do this sort of like
geodesic dome thing with this thing then
it turns into this thing so this is like
a little hot it's a little hard to see
but so I don't can see this right so
these four triangles the the three on
the outside are slightly isosceles and
the one in the middle is actually
equilateral so this is subdivided than
then and then the vertices to the extra
vertices just squished around a little
bit to make it make it a bit smoother
and then it's it's nicer right it's sort
of you can get quite large bits of it to
be flat or you can't get all of it to be
flat it always sort of bunches up
somewhere no matter how hard you try
looks like a doily yeah it's a
hyperbolic doily that's what it is
it really likes to be in sort of like
saddles or crinkly star for yeah fun to
play with on the short side so long side
is n the short side is n minus one so
each rectangle is n times n minus 1
there's three of them so there's three
lots of that and then there's one in the
middle well right so that's a really
hard question okay all right here we go